this week Eric loves tech asks are any
tablets hardware apps OS good for people
giving presentations conferences
classroom sales etc Eric it turns out
that tablets are very capable of giving
presentations and they're much easier to
bring into the conference room than a
big clunky laptop but the key to getting
things started comes in a word that no
tech journalist likes to sale out a
dongle for the iPad Apple sells a $50
digital AV Adapter that makes it very
easy to connect the tablet to a TV and
most projectors for Microsoft and
Android tablets there are many universal
micro USB to HDMI adapter it's actually
how I'm able to give this presentation
right now on the Galaxy Note pro you can
also use wireless display features like
Apple's AirPlay or DLNA and some Windows
tablets have some form of video out
right on the tablet software is easy
this week I reviewed tablets with all
the major platforms Android iOS and
Windows and all of them have
alternatives to PowerPoint
Apple has keynote google has
presentations in its drive suite and
Windows has authentic PowerPoint just be
aware if you're buying a tablet with the
full version of Windows 8 you have to
buy the full version of Office to get
PowerPoint presenting on tablets is as
easy as swiping on the screen but if you
want to walk around the room you can get
a Bluetooth remote control there's this
one called the digit 2 our last tip just
don't make those presentations too
boring and we want to hear more of your
questions send them to us on Twitter or
Facebook with the hashtag ask WS JD now
back to my very important presentation